Donald Trump is set to unveil his tax
plan this is the latest train wreck in
the ongoing gongshow of disasters it's
going to propose cutting corporate taxes
on the foreign profits of American
companies Trump said oh it's all about
helping American workers my campaign is
going to be great for American workers
we're going to bring back the
working-class how do you help American
workers if you make it so that it's more
profitable for US corporations to make
money in other countries by reducing the
taxes that they would have to pay in
addition to that Donald Trump plans to
slash the top tax rate on so-called
pass-through business income from thirty
nine point six percent to fifteen
percent so this is actually something
that impacts me as an individual I think
it's terrible policy this would save me
money on my taxes every year but I think
it's terrible policy pass-through
business income is taxed on a business
owners tax return at their individual
income tax rate okay so for example the
david pakman show is part of what's
called an S corporation right and by
virtue of having under some threshold of
shareholders I think it's 20 or 25 the
business itself doesn't really pay taxes
so at the end of the year our accountant
comes to me and says David the David
Pakman show as a business owes some
minimum tax it's usually $600 or
something like that the income that the
business generates passes through to the
shareholders right so I at the end of
the year get something called a k1 forum
which says here's my distribution as an
owner of the David Pakman show and when
I do my personal taxes I punch that in
and I pay taxes income tax on that based
on my personal income tax rate okay so
you might hear this and say well David
that that sounds really good it's going
to help so many people because small
business owners will now be able to pay
only 15% on pass-through business income
rather than maybe 25 or the 28% or even
more if they make more income that they
would pay on that pass-through income
but here's the trickery it
overwhelmingly disproportionately helps
the super-rich once you earn more than
thirty seven thousand nine hundred and
fifty dollars for the year you're in the
fifth in the twenty five percent income
tax bracket right once you get to ninety
one thousand nine hundred dollars for
the year in income you're in the
twenty-eight percent tax bracket so you
can look at it and say wow that's great
Donald Trump is going to make it so that
all business owners who make as little
as thirty seven thousand nine hundred
and fifty dollars are going to get a tax
cut and that's true but in terms of the
dollar amount the tax cut that your
business owner making forty thousand
dollars is going to get is tiny tiny in
comparison to what the individuals at
the thirty nine point six percent tax
bracket sometimes making millions upon
millions of dollars per year are going
to get in fact an analysis has already
been done the tax break on pass-through
income that Donald Trump is going to
propose will disproportionately benefit
the wealthiest three percent of business
owners and business partners not to
mention that the people more likely to
earn pass-through income are already
more likely to be wealthier anyway so
your average small business sole
proprietorship is passed through income
already in the sense that there's no
business entity right you have a plumber
who just is you know Joe plumber a sole
proprietorship they're completely
unaffected by this in that they will
continue to pay income tax at their
prevailing income tax rates so how is
this all going to be paid for by the way
because we know that these tax cuts
disproportionately for the rich increase
the budget deficit well the Tax Policy
centers analysis says that this plan
would cause a loss of two point four
trillion dollars in government revenue
over ten years and there is no end
that enough loopholes are closed or that
you are cutting enough to make this
balance out and it is you know we're
hearing from the tax Treasury Secretary
rather Stephen minuchin that this is
going to pay for itself until we see
evidence of that don't believe it for a
second because these tax cuts for the
rich rarely if ever pay for themselves
and this is yet another trumple benefit
from this his buddies will benefit from
this and some small business owners true
small business owners will slightly
benefit from it but this is not the boon
to the average worker that Donald Trump
promised send me your thoughts on this
okay I'm on Twitter at the Pakman and
the show is on Twitter at David Pakman
show I know people have been waiting for
me to comment on this and my comments
are this is the exact opposite of what
Trump promised it is the exact thing we
assumed Trump would do with the tax code
at his earliest possible opportunity I'm
excited to tell you that today's episode
of the show is made possible by a great
new advertiser that we have taga dabbe
the hosting specialist they offer a
range of affordable flexible hosting
packages including dedicated VPS and
cloud server options as well as having
the ability to put together custom
server solutions for you your business
your project they have 70% of their
business coming from repeat orders and
recommendations and their Trustpilot
review rating is excellent at nine point
seven out of ten with more and more
people interested in moving their
businesses or their projects to the
cloud tag a dab is currently offering
new customers a ten-pound
signup credit which gives you the
opportunity to try the service they are
based in the UK you can be based
anywhere in the world to take advantage
of this offer you can simply go to
signup tag adapt comm slash TDPS that's
signup dot ta ga da b.com /t dps support
our new sponsor and support the David
Pakman show